foreign
[Music]
also the bank called
hey brother Joe I got something to tell
you dad I better call yesterday from a
guy at a record company he says he heard
our record and uh our record
what do you mean dreaming wild
great to meet you I wanted to talk to
you about this there it is it's raining
wild that's you guys yeah that's us this
album is unbelievable truly it really
just blew my
how did you do it
Donnie made it all right here
Johnny what you got going on over there
I'm just playing around Donny's a genius
and then what happened we're gonna need
some more money to get these last few
songs finished my dad lost a lot we find
albums that never found an audience we
try to give them a second chance and
based on all the buzz the record has got
because you've seen that right during
its finest moments to twist the Brian
Wilson phrase dreaming wild is a Godlike
Symphony to Dean Hood all right Wilson
yeah
well heck let's celebrate
you got a gift
you gotta use it I believe in you boys
New York Times want to do a story on you
guys are you kidding me
should be the kickoff for a tour so
weird to have this now I'm not sure what
to do with all of it
[Music]
spent my whole life trying to make music
it's just fun for you it's not just fun
for me
[Music]
just didn't know anything about the
world
a lot easier when I was a teenager
[Music]
sorry to have for putting you through
all of it
you're my son
I would have gladly given up all the
land just here you play